[Music]  the gods foretold of this day when a  champion from the mascara would be  called upon to protect man's world  you're a princess right something like  that  Diana explain yourself  his arrival is a sign man's world needs  our help  are you truly willing to throw away  everything you are for the mere chance  of helping them it's what you taught me  it's Wonder Woman blaster  I take it deliberations are over it did  not go well you really are something  special you know that so please I'm sure  it's been a long time  giganto bigger and better be  I do so love mass destruction though you  haven't beaten me yet poison and  Cybermen have declared war on Venice  Karen and if there's one thing  Amazon's know it's how to fight a war  and it's time to fight show me the path  to the mascara  show me the way home  you just had to wait for the dramatic  entrance didn't you I thought you liked  a little drama  [Music]